bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 60,18 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 10 mars
distribution de repas à part des
associations plan d'action des
responsables politiques la précarité
étudiante inquiète donc cette édition
nous parlerons des opérations menées par
l'association élan coeur à l encontre et
des nouvelles mesures prévues par le
conseil départemental nucléaire jeu ben
ali c'est le nom de cette association
qui milite actuellement pour obtenir
l'installation d'une sonde de mesure de
la radioactivité à andrésy nous verrons
les enjeux de ce dossier nous évoquerons
la sûreté nucléaire
avec maxime morin de l'institut de
radioprotection dans le département et
puis direction büchi également à la fin
de ce journal pour découvrir le coc
living un mode de vie alliant espace
privé et espace partagé
comme je vous le disais en titre la
précarité étudiante est au coeur des
préoccupations
c'est un phénomène qui a été accentuée
par la crise sanitaire
une distribution de colis alimentaires a
eu lieu à elancourt aujourd'hui pour
aider ces jeunes c'est l'association
élan coeur qui est en est à l'origine
200 colis alimentaires avec des produits
de base des pas du lait de l'huile du
sucre des gâteaux ont été remis
l'association à financer l'intégralité
des denrées on écoute son président
c'est vraiment un plaisir pour nous un
honneur de venir en aide à ces étudiants
qui sont l'avenir de notre pays qui sont
l'avenir de la société et on voulait
vraiment faire les accompagner au delà
d'elle au delà de l'aide alimentaire
colorants qu'on leur apporte
c'est vraiment leur dire que voilà on
est là on fait société ensemble c'est un
message c'est un message de solidarité
qu'on leur apporte
autre action pour lutter contre la
précarité des étudiants le département
des yvelines va investir plus d'un vu
deux millions d'euros en partenariat
avec l'université versailles saint
quentin et le crous de versailles des
aides alimentaires vont être mises en
place mais aussi des aides financières
le reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas dandy le département
des yvelines au chevet de ses étudiants
à travers des mesures pour lutter contre
la précarité des opérations de
l'alimentaire vont être mises en place
l'épicerie agora est situé à guyancourt
va devenir itinérante l'iut de
mantes-la-jolie va pouvoir bénéficier du
restaurant scolaire du collège de
gassicourt et le département va aussi
compléter leur part à un euro dans les
crous mise en place par l'état c'est la
prise en charge par le département de
l'euro qui reste ce n'est donc pas prise
en charge par l'état
donc nous allons faire ça avec le crous
qui est le gestionnaire des restaurants
universitaires les étudiants vont aussi
bénéficier des aides financières une
rémunération en échange d'un travail
avec un partenaire ou à travers des
dispositifs départementaux existants
nous allons élargir à 500 le nombre
d'emplois pour accompagner les seniors
nous allons aussi favorisé cet emploi
étudiants en les rémunérant pour faire
du soutien scolaire auprès des enfants
qui nous sont confiées et nous allons
aussi créer une vingtaine de jobs pour
aider les associations alimentaires ces
mesures complètent les actions mises en
oeuvre par l'université versailles saint
quentin et le crous de versailles
on a aidé dans la première phase plus de
mille étudiants ou à peu près sur
dix-huit mille étudiants et donc on a
fait une aide qui s'élève je crois
surtout ces êtres autour de 260 milles
euros
au total le département des yvelines va
investir plus d'un million deux cent
mille euros
actuellement huit étudiants sur 10
disent avoir subi des préjudices à cause
de la crise sanitaire d'après un sondage
au doxa backbone avant d'entamer notre
page sur la radioactivité les actions
pour la mesurer en france une
information
le préavis de grève des cars pour toul a
été levée ce matin une grève était
prévue demain jeudi 11 mars mais un
accord a été trouvé entre les
partenaires sociaux et la direction des
cars pour toul
par conséquent l'ensemble des lignes
circuleront normalement ce jeudi 11 mars
nous ouvrons donc cette page sur la
radioactivité ces instruments de mesure
juste avant d'accueillir notre invité en
plateau maxime morin qui travaille à
l'institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire située en partie au
vésinet l'association nucléaire je
balise basé dans la vallée de seine au
nord-est des yvelines milite pour
implanter une sonde à andrésy l'objectif
serait de mesurer de manière
indépendante la radioactivité sur le
territoire de l'île de france
un projet soutenu par la municipalité
reportage de nicolas landry mélanie poké
une sonde pour mesurer de manière
indépendante la radioactivité le projet
qui pourrait voir le jour sur la commune
d'andrésy c'est l'objectif de
l'association yvelinoise nucléaire je
balise un collectif d'une vingtaine de
militants actifs co créé par gilles
cousin la sonde
elle est pour toute l'île de france à
partir du moment où elle soupçonne ces
cas une pollution radioactive assez
importante parce qu'effectivement il n'y
a pas énormément d'installation en
ile-de-france informations et
transparence sur la radioactivité c'est
tout l'enjeu autour de cette sonde les
résultats seraient répertoriées et
analysés par l'association criirad
la commission de recherche et
d'information indépendantes sur la
radioactivité
il existe des sondes officiel mais ce
champ des sont donc qui dépendent en
grande partie de l'état évidemment
certains acteurs du nucléaire donc il
nous semble important en démocratie qui
est une autre chose est évidemment une
source indépendante d'informations pour
être accompagné dans sa démarche
l'association a sollicité la
municipalité la commune trouve un
intérêt dans ce projet une
sensibilisation aux citoyens du risque
environnemental qui malheureusement qui
peut arriver tout le temps par et d
impact aura bien deux industriels ou
environnementaux le coût de l'achat et
de l'installation de cet équipement
atteint les 45000 euros
l'association a répondu à l'appel à
projets dans le cadre du budget
participatif de la région objectif
obtenir une subvention de 10000 euros le
reste fera l'objet d'une campagne de
financement citoyenne et pour continuer
à parler de sûreté nucléaire nous
accueillons en plateau avec nous maxime
morin bonsoir bonsoir
alors je le rappelle vous êtes le chef
du laboratoire de surveillance de
l'environnement par échantillonnage au
sein de l'institut de radioprotection et
de sûreté nucléaire
on va dire ali rsm d'abord que pensez
vous de ce que l'association nucléaire
je balise gens me dire dans le reportage
vouloir des mesures indépendantes de
celles de l'état en matière de
radioactivité
alors effectivement actuellement la
radioactivité est surveillé par un
réseau qui est géré par l'irsn ce soir
de protection et de sûreté nucléaire
mais après chaque association ou
collectivité locale peut décider
effectivement d'installer d'autres sont
complémentaires et faire ses propres
mesures
de toute façon tous les résultats
notamment de cette surveillance va dire
régaliennes qui est assurée par l'irsn
sont mis en ligne notamment sur internet
en temps réel et donc c'est un réseau
qui viendra de toute façon en complément
si les associations veulent veulent
transmettre ces résultats alors libérées
saines l'institut donc vous travaillez
situé au vésinet en partie donc dans les
yvelines
il est chargé de surveiller les risques
liés à la radioactivité en france
si je ne me trompe pas 438 balises sont
installés dans notre pays mais aussi à
l'étranger
quelle est la radioactivité que l'on
mesure que l'on observe en france et
quel impact at elle également
alors en fait on n'a pas une seule
valeur de la radioactivité en france
puisqu'il faut savoir qu'une grande
partie de la radioactivité
dû à des causes on va dire naturelles
notamment la radioactivité dit
telluriques qui est lié au sol avec
notamment du potassium 40 de l'uranium
qui sont présents dans les sols et
également à ce qu'on appelle des cosmo
génique c'est à dire des atomes des on
va dire des isotopes qui sont formés
dans l'atmosphère sous l'effet des
rayonnements cosmiques donc selon qu'on
soit en montagne ou en plaine selon
qu'on soit sur des sols plus ragnetti
coûts peuvent avoir des variations de ce
qu'on appelle le bruit de son de la
radioactivité en france avec des valeurs
qui varie de on va dire 60 nanosievert
par heure nanosievert par heure que
l'unité de doses
pas toujours facile de s'y retrouver la
radioactivité ambiante on va dire à des
niveaux plus élevés par exemple dans des
zones comme l'image ou la bretagne sur
le massif armoricain où on a des valeurs
plus élevées de bruit de fond du fait
notamment de cette radio activité
tellurique
donc l'impact sur les gens sur au
quotidien est ce qu'il ya un réel impact
de cette radioactivité que vous dites
des bruits de fond alors cette
radioactivité de bruit de fond en fait
tout ce qui est autour de nous et
radioactifs
donc notre alimentation est radio active
notre conjoint et radioactifs c'est
rassure tu as fait c'est pas pour ça que
c'est dangereux c'est à dire que les
doses qui sont mis en jeu sont
relativement faibles donc l'irsn fait
une évaluation de la dose moyenne des
français qui intègre les examens
médicaux éventuellement réaliser qu'ils
peuvent être fortement d'auzan comme par
exemple certains types de scanners ou
des radiothérapies dans le cas du
traitement des cancers mais également de
ses composantes naturelles
on a un impact aussi sur des choses
qu'on connaît un petit peu moins mais
par exemple le tabagisme puisque
lorsqu'on fume on va y aller des
radionucléides lorsqu'on va être
construit à consommer des fruits de mer
puisque les fruits de mer vont avoir
tendance à filtrer plein de ton qui lui
même est un petit peu plus radioactifs
donc on va avoir en fonction de chaque
français une exposition qui va varier
mais qui n'est pas dangereuse pour la
santé alors 25 sont téléray comme celle
que veut implanter l'association sont
installés en île de france et sont gérés
par l'ia rsm leurs données sont mises en
ligne vous la ville de chaleur en temps
réel chaque jour ils sont accessibles au
public sur le site téléray points hier
et scène point fr que vous voyez
s'afficher un autre site plus simple
regroupe l'entièreté des données de la
rsm que vous voyez également s'afficher
en bas de votre écran
pourquoi mettre en ligne ces données est
ce que c'est dans
de transparence justement de l'état et
de l'hyères sm oui tout à fait ans alors
on a deux types de mesures cessons de
téléray c'est vraiment notre réseau
dallaire donc c'est vraiment la colonne
dans la moelle épinière on va dire du
système de surveillance
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir une mesure
toutes les 10 minutes sur toutes ses
sondes ces quatre cent quarante secondes
y compris outre mer qui vont nous donner
une photographie toutes les 10 minutes
de la radioactivité sur le territoire
français donc il va nous permettre de
lancer la l'erc si on voit une élévation
après on va réaliser aussi pour
comprendre la radioactivité des
prélèvements et donc ces prélèvements il
va être analysé en laboratoire c'est un
petit peu plus long et donc on avait
besoin via ce réseau téléray de donner
ces renseignements en temps réel aux
citoyens et en parallèle de déverser les
résultats de mesure sur des temps qui
peut être un peu plus long alors
pourquoi cette transparence d'une part
parce que aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'informer les citoyens sur la
radioactivité c'est une attente légitime
des citoyens
ensuite parce que le législateur lui
même a fait évolué au fil des années la
réglementation et aujourd'hui on a des
attentes fortes non seulement des
citoyens mais également des pouvoirs
publics en matière de transparence et
mise à disposition de la des résultats
de radioactivité dans l'environnement
donc l'idée de ces deux sites internet
c'était vraiment de rendre accessible à
tous ces mesures de radioactivité on va
s'éloigner un peu des yvelines
maintenant mes deux actualités vous fait
parler de la radioactivité
récemment d'abord du césium 137 donc une
partie donc c'est un composant
radioactif qui a été détecté à la suite
d'un passage du nuage de sable provenant
du sahara c'était début février
est ce donc de la région lyonnaise
jusqu'en normandie dont quand même grand
zone en france ces particules aurait des
effets minimes sur la santé lire sn a
lui aussi est détecté une présence plus
élevé que la moyenne de ceux césium 137
à cette période doit-on s'habituer à ce
genre de phénomène qui est finalement
une conséquence du passé puisque ces
particules remonterait à des essais
nucléaires
donc datant des années 60 dans le sahara
alors on y est déjà habitué puisque en
fait lors des épisodes de vent saharien
précédent il y en a assez régulièrement
on avait déjà ses traces de césium donc
là ça revient parce qu'effectivement on
a eu un épisode de grande ampleur bien
on a vu des photos un peu spectaculaire
à strasbourg
et je cite c'est rare que ça remonte aux
aussi haut en revanche c'est assez
fréquent qu'on voit ces épisodes et
qu'on puisse détecté de la radioactivité
alors pourquoi puisqu'en fait des essais
nucléaires atmosphériques réalisés dans
le sahara
dans les années 60 c'est tout premier
essai nucléaire français
alors il faut savoir que quatre essais
réalisés dit atmosphérique c'est-à-dire
à l'air libre dans le sahara et qu'à
l'époque jusqu'au début des années 60
les américains et soviétiques en ont
réalisé deux cent vingt donc en fait
dans tout l'hémisphère nord on retrouve
ce césium qui va être remobiliser lors
de ces épisodes de vent ça a rien à des
niveaux qui restent extrêmement faibles
c'est vraiment des niveaux de traces
donc on peut détecter une augmentation
lorsqu'on a des moyens de prélèvements
et des moyens de mesure qu'ils sont
suffisamment puissants mais en pratique
même avec cette élévation on reste quand
même très très bas en terme de
radioactivité
on est autour de 1 dans ces épisodes
l'a21 microbecquerels par mètre cube
donc c'est à dire 10 - 6 becquerel par
mètre cube donc des niveaux qui sont
extrêmement faibles notamment comparé
des niveaux de radioactivité naturelle
l'autre actualité récente la
quasi-totalité des polynésiens auraient
été exposées à la radioactivité lors de
l'essai français centaure en 1974 selon
une enquête du média d'investigation en
ligne disclose qui est sorti hier
au total cela représenterait cent dix
mille personnes à l'époque l'état
français n'avait pas alerté la
population est ce possible de découvrir
redécouvrir un pareil phénomène d'ici
quelques années
alors il ya eu en polynésie 41 essais
nucléaires qui ont été réalisés
atmosphérique la plupart des essais ont
été réalisés sont dissous terrain parce
qu'ils ont été réalisés dans des puits
qui était foré dans les atolls en
pratique l'irsn met en place une
surveillance de l'environnement sur la
polynésie qui va non seulement
comprendre une surveillance des sols une
surveillance des denrées qu'ils sont
consommés par les polynésiens aussi bien
des légumes que des boissons etc
et puis on va avoir une surveillance de
l'air également qui est réalisée on a un
laboratoire de l'irsn qui est basé
depuis les années 60 en polynésie à
vairao en l'occurrence il a changé
d'emplacement mais aujourd'hui il est à
vairao avec un sortons de l'analyse et
donc on fait une estimation nous qui a
régulièrement des rapports qui sont
produits par l'irsn sur l'estimation de
la douche
vis-à-vis des polynésiens donc
aujourd'hui on est une dose qui est
imputable à la radioactivité
artificielle en polynésie qui représente
un millième de la radioactivité
naturelle
donc c'est comme ça qu'ils iraient scène
assure cette surveillance là alors on ne
fait pas de surveillance au niveau des
atolls de même où ces essais ont été
réalisés mais on fait une surveillance
de l'environnement à la fois sur la
chaîne alimentaire et surtout ce qui est
production agricole en polynésie mais
également au niveau des sols pour les
retombées des essais merci maxime morin
pour toutes ces précisions et d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau feu dans le
reste de l'actualité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'école estaca
forme des ingénieurs dans tous les
domaines l'un d'eux c'est la filière
spatiale présentation de cette formation
qui ne forme pas que des astronautes sur
les images d'astrid bergère et mélanie
poké quand on pense au spatial
on pense souvent aux astronautes mais la
filière regorge de différents métiers à
l'école d'ingénieurs l'estaca situé en
partie à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
professeurs et étudiants tentent de
faire connaître la filière au plus grand
nombre
c'est une filière qui était censé donc
se développer à partir de la filière
aéronautique donc qui concernaient un
nombre limité d'étudiants de plus en
plus de
d'étudiants veulent y travailler d'une
part parce que ça passionne beaucoup de
monde
et puis deuxièmement il ya quand même de
plus en plus donc de demandes de besoin
dans dans l'industrie dans cette
formation ni rentrer avec déjà un bac +
3 qui peut s'effectuer au sein de
l'école d'ingénieur puis deux ans pour
comprendre et apprendre ce qui se trame
dans l'organisation d'une mission
spatiale mais aussi sur tous ceux qui y
contribuent à son hôte sse et j'aime
bien cette image là déjà payé sel c'est
la partie immergée de l'iceberg à dire
qu'il sait ce qu'on voit en premier par
contre il ya beaucoup de travail de fond
derrière pour arriver à faire une
mission spatiale qui fait travailler
énormément de deux personnes des
scientifiques des ingénieurs parmi les
étudiants de la filière spatiale de
l'estaca manon bordeaux en quatrième
année
son rêve travailler sur la propulsion
des fusées son ambition devenir
ingénieur d'essai moteur au sein d'un
grand groupe spatiale trouve ça
merveilleux de pouvoir travailler dans
ce domaine là et de lancer des hommes
des femmes qui pour accomplir leur rêve
d'aller dans l'espace et enfin déjà rien
que voir sa fusée décoller c'est un
accomplissement de tout le projet de
tout le travail qu'on a fait dessus donc
c'est déjà magnifique à l'estaca plus de
2000 étudiants sont formés chaque année
aux différents métiers de l'ingénierie
pour manon bordeaux comme pour dj gignac
l'avenir de la filière spatiale est
assurée la conquête spatiale ne fait que
commencer
c'est un concept originaire de la côte
ouest des états unis que nous allons
vous présenter à présent le coc living
est de plus en plus fréquent en france
ce mode de vie alliant espace privé et
espace partagé offre colocataires des
services plus variés se rapprochant de
ceux d'un hôtel à buc un ancien hôtel
justement a été réaménagé les précisions
de bixente mais rien senti steban evina
nip ok ils sont arrivés la semaine
dernière mais se sentent déjà comme chez
eux dans cet ancien hôtel de buc
transformée en établissement de co
living une dizaine de jeunes et
professionnels en déplacement se
partagent désormais l'espace jeunes
seulement pour six mois
c'était assez idéale de se dire qu'on
puisse arriver avec sa valise se pose et
repartir quand on veut et par le même
biais de pouvoir faire des connaissances
des amis avoir un peu de la vie autour
de nous c'est plus l'idée de rencontrer
des jeunes comme en région débutants
six amis trois étages aménagé en
vingt-et-une chambre pour les occupants
avec cuisine salle à manger est un
espace coaching pour christophe dulong
propriétaire des lieux cette
reconversion est le fruit d'une
évolution sociétale avec les nouveaux
modes de fonctionnement qui sont
actuelle mais qui vont perdurer
il y aurait moins de déplacements moins
de déplacements par le moins de
formation beaucoup de plus de choses qui
soient en télétravail ou en formation à
distance et donc les déplacements
d'affaires à mon avis vont souffrir
une entreprise spécialisée en caux
living a été engagée elle accompagne les
investisseurs autour des travaux à
réaliser jusqu'à la gestion des
locataires on est quand même sur les
gens qui qui sont presque des jeunes
actifs qui sont pas forcément de la
région oranaise qui les noms des régions
où ils déménagent pour
pour des raisons très sport
professionnel et donc du coup c'est les
aider à s'intégrer à rencontrer du monde
alors aussi alors offrir aussi un espace
confortable et une démarche aussi
simplifié dans la partie administrative
c'est le plus gros espaces gérés par la
société
bien que ce mode de colocation xxl soit
de plus en plus courant pour les loyers
ils vont de 680 euros par mois à 800
euros pour les grandes suites avec salle
de bains toilettes et kitchenette pour
refermer ce journal direction
vélizy-villacoublay londe théâtre centre
d'art présente une exposition en
extérieur dans la ville mais aussi à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel de ville
27 jeunes de la commune sont mises à
l'honneur à travers des portraits justin
brasier et astrid berges r27 portraits
de jeunes habitants de vélizy sont
exposées dans la commune et à l'hôtel de
ville depuis le 12 février
c'est long deux théâtres centres d'art
qui à l'origine de cette exposition et
des parents photographe et graphiste
l'objectif c'est de mettre en avant à un
moment tout l'intérêt que nous portons
cette jeunesse qui aujourd'hui plus que
jamais est touché par la situation
sanitaire
touchés dans ces études dont deux
touchés dans ses relations amicales
touché dans ses relations sociales un
appareil le photographe a passé cinq ou
six semaines a immortalisé ces jeunes à
travers ses clichés
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était important
d'inscrire l'ondh dans le portrait donc
j'ai fait des cadrages assez large avec
l'idée que le décor avait son importance
dans l'image et racontait aussi son
histoire la relation du jeune à londres
et en même temps comme c'est la jeunesse
je pense que c'était important pour moi
d'avoir les jeunes en pied c'est à dire
en fait que la posture et son importance
dans l'image aussi c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi de faire les cadrages assez
large pour cette exposition le
photographe a travaillé avec anne
athlètes une graphiste
on a travaillé chacun de notre côté mais
en se coordonnant pire que moi j'ai fait
mon travail de portraits avec les jeunes
et j'ai donné à n'être le corpus d'image
terminée et retouchée mais avec des
cadrages suffisamment large pour qu'elle
puisse intervenir avant tout elle est là
elle a construit un décor avec les
lettres qu'elle a émis imaginé pour le
avec le prénom des jeunes qu'on a
photographié et j'ai cru que c'était une
super idée franchement moi je suis assez
content du résultat
l'exposition sera visible dans le hall
de la mairie de vélizy villacoublay
jusqu'au 30 avril
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée
[Musique]